je regrette de n'en voir pas beaucoup de
courage dans cette hémicycle à ce moment
précis je vois
je vois je vois pas mal de l'acheter
chez certains d'entre vous s'il vous
plaît
dans la manière que vous avez décidé de
fuir le débat
dans la manière que vous avez
de tout faire pour refuser le vote le
vote qui vous donnerait tort
dans votre manière de tout faire pour
pas donner satisfaction 87% de Français
qui aujourd'hui réclame la pollution de
la corrida en France
je vous ai demandé tout à l'heure
si vous pouviez être à la hauteur de
votre mandat en permettant la tenue d'un
débat digne sur ce sujet
en retirant tous les amendements
d'obstruction au moment où je vous parle
aucun d'entre eux n'a été retiré
il reste plus de 80 il reste plus de 480
amendements à étudier avec un rythme de
20 amendements à l'heure ça représente
24 heures de débat bien sûr vous l'avez
fait pour la qualité des échanges
monsieur le rapporteur s'il vous plaît
je demande quelques instants s'il vous
plaît chers collègues merci bien vouloir
écouter rapporteur jusqu'au bout mais
sur la porteur si vous pouviez aller au
fait de votre réaction
[Applaudissements]
je veux quand même car les Français nous
regardent je veux quand même leur donner
des exemples des amendements que vous
avez déposés pour que nous puissions pas
travailler aujourd'hui
amendement pour former un torero sur le
bien-être animal
un moment pour maintenir la corrida en
prévoyant une piqûre contre la douleur
[Applaudissements]
amendement pour que les corridas ne
puissent pas se dérouler lorsqu'il fait
plus de 40 degrés à l'extérieur voilà
comment vous travaillez il faut que les
Français soient au courant
à cet instant à cet instant je pense à
tous les Français qui attendaient
tellement de cette journée
je pense
à ces millions de Françaises et de
Français qui se sont mobilisés avec un
espoir qu'enfin on en finit avec cette
exception intolérable et indigne de
notre pays
je pense
je pense au dizaines d'associations qui
se sont mobilisés
et pour lesquelles ce jour était un jour
historique
[Musique]
je n'ose imaginer ce que toutes ces
personnes pensent pendant qu'elle nous
observent à l'instant même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une évidence ça me coûte de le
reconnaître
oui ça me nave
et je tiens je tiens à m'en excuser
je tiens à m'en excuser auprès de celles
et ceux qui ont tellement compté sur
nous
pour obtenir une victoire historique
mais je dois bien je dois bien me
résoudre je dois bien me rendre à
l'évidence nous ne pourrons pas abolir
la corrida en France aujourd'hui
applaudissez soyez fier de vous
[Applaudissements]
je tiens à rassurer celles et ceux qui
nous écoutent
ce qui vient de se passer aujourd'hui
ce qui
[Musique]
ce qui vient de se passer aujourd'hui
n'est pas une fin si on est un peu à la
télé madame sachez qu'on nous regarde
sachez que les Français peuvent voir ce
qui se passe dans cette hémicycle et je
les invite à regarder ce qui se passe
ici
journaliste oui c'est un métier honteux
c'est ça que vous voulez dire c'est une
adjectif pour vous non
pour le bien des français
s'il vous plaît
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui n'est pas
une fin mais ce n'est qu'un début
[Applaudissements]
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui n'est pas
une fin ce n'est qu'un début avec mes
collègues de la France insoumise je vais
déposer une nouvelle proposition de loi
une loi transpartisane
qui sera inscrite à nos débats dans le
cadre d'une semaine de l'assemblée
et j'invite tous mes collègues de tous
les groupes parce que je sais que vous
êtes nombreux et nombreuses dans chaque
groupe à vouloir la fin de la corrida je
vous invite chers collègues est-ce que
nous travaillons ensemble pour avoir une
victoire collective qu'attendent de nous
tous les Français et les Français
la corrida sera bientôt abolie dans ce
pays je le promets nous le promettons
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente vous l'avez compris
pour aujourd'hui malheureusement je suis
contraint contraint de retirer ce texte
[Applaudissements]